excusez-moi vous avez pas vu l'émission
donc demande à Mathieu par exemple à
Mathieu par exemple cette phrase vient
dans quel contexte et parle après qui
est comment ça se passe mais il y a pas
toujours besoin d'un contexte si je sors
une phrase horrible il y a pas besoin de
contexte pour la justifier là c'est pas
justifié ça juste de savoir le contexte
et le thématique globale c'est quoi la
thématique de l'émission
tu vois si je dis Géraldine est une
grosse conne bah non je m'arrête là et
que j'ai pas dit avant ce qui se passe
avant ou après peu importe mais la
phrase la phrase en elle-même est
horrible il dit ça plutôt de moi
jamais mon cœur
donc il parle effectivement le thème
c'est effectivement internet en prison
est-ce que il faut que les prisonniers
et Internet en prison et la femme qui
parle Emmanuel Dancourt qui est très
brillante dit elle a priori oui elle est
d'accord pour tous les prisonniers et
lui dit maman moi je suis pas d'accord
parce que qui quoi comment c'est-à-dire
est-ce qu'on va donner la comme il
disait à un je sais pas un pédo criminel
Internet est-ce qu'on va donner un
théoriste Internet et du mélange tout
pardon tu mélanges
ils n'ont pas le droit d'avoir internet
sans penser qu'ils sont les
sous-citoyens la société elle a raison
Béatrice qui a choqué on ne peut pas
dire aujourd'hui
ça veut dire qu'ils n'ont ils sont ils
sont mis hors la loi et comme l'a dit
très bien des fines en ce sens ils n'ont
pas les mêmes droits que ceux qui sont
morts
pour l'ensemble des hommes
et même
pas et donc de ce fait ils se sont
exclus de la société ils ont décidé
d'être hors la hors de la société et
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont en prison
ils sont c'est complètement vaseux ils
sont privés de liberté Géraldine ils
sont privés de liberté et
parce que ils ont fait une faute une
erreur
privé de liberté ce sont des citoyens
qui ont été jugés et donc ils ont voté
sur les citoyens qui ont voté voilà
c'est tout mais ils sont pas des sous
citoyens d'accord qu'en prison ils sont
quand même enfermés ils n'ont pas le
droit par exemple d'aller venir
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît ce sont
des citoyens qui sont qui ont voté voilà
ce qu'on veut ce sont des citoyens ce ne
sont pas des sous-citoyens ils n'ont pas
les mêmes droits que les citoyens qui
sont présents
c'est pas un sous-entend c'est un enfant
qui est puni non mais et qui va qui va
voilà qui va être puni qui reviendra
ensuite tu vois ce que je veux dire non
mais merci de me faire une explication
texte je comprends très bien ce que tu
dis maintenant mais c'est pas mal ce
qu'il dit mais malgré tout pour moi sous
citoyen c'est encore une fois c'est pas
sous homme ou sous race en fait
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a plus de droit
civique donc il n'a plus rien dans la
société
pour les terroristes par exemple
tu considères les terroristes comme les
sous-citoyens gilberté
si tu considères les terroristes comme
les sous-citoyens
et ben Gilles Verdez non donc
excusez-moi moi je considère les petits
comme des sous-citoyens ils sont privés
de leurs droits civique tu as le droit
de les avoir
citoyennes
dans ce cadre-là des théories vous avez
vu la séquence avant non mais il parle
des pédocrinels et des terroristes non
mais désolé
les prisonniers sont des sous citoyens
c'est voilà c'est voilà il y a plein de
prisonniers qui nous regardent je peux
vous dire ce sont pas des sous-citoyens
voilà je suis désolé ce sont des
citoyens qui ont voté
les terroristes exactement les gens les
gens c'est les gens dans les prisons
c'est pas les terroristes et les
pédophiles comme ça effectivement c'est
c'est assez choc je suis d'accord mais
sauf que ça vient dans un contexte où je
trouve que c'est très clair moi
personnellement en tout cas ça
c'est-à-dire quand un enfant fait une
bêtise ok c'est pas un sous-entend mais
en fait un enfant c'est un mot tu vois
comment puis un adulte c'est un mot
commun mais le mot citoyen c'est pas
tout à fait un mot commun c'est un c'est
un statut tu comprends c'est un grade et
tu l'acquières si tu rentres dans c'est
un citoyen de la République donc voilà
voilà citoyen et tu honores ton grade de
citoyen de la République
Géraldine si on parle du terme citoyen
il y a à peu près 98% des prisonniers
qui ont le droit de vote ils peuvent
voter par procuration on pense même
peut-être installer des urnes en prison
pour les grandes élections donc le mot
citoyen ils sont des citoyens puisqu'ils
votent après justement on l'entend
plutôt comme sous homme on est tous à
peu près
dans la même dans le même esprit donc il
a voilà il semblait penser quand il
s'est énervé qu'il l'a dit c'est ce
qu'on a vu dans ses yeux mais on peut se
tromper non moi je trouve pas mais après
vous avez le droit de le penser ça me
dérange
elle le connaît mieux que nous